and it sounds like after the camera
stopped rolling the party continued at
the white house well i
what is what is true is we had some good
parties at the white house whoo they're
they're they're
i mean part of it is the fact that you
know we had amazing people like bruce
who were willing to play
and uh it turns out that
folks
if they're at a good party they don't
want to go home even when it's the white
house
so
it would go late sometimes oh yeah and
people people misbehaved uh in ways i
would not have expected under uh the
portrait of george washington and martha
watson
yeah no nothing nothing you know nothing
uh illegal but uh yeah fair enough
you're okay it's done now it's trump in
that scandal and you know you talk about
these amazing people you got to form at
the white house did anyone turn you down
was there anyone you couldn't get
honestly no
you know
one of the one of the most uh remarkable
performances we had
at a party in the white house
he did technically turn us down the
first time and that was uh prince
in fact in the book i think there's a
picture of me
dancing with sasha on stage
with the prince playing in the
background
it was actually
probably two months three months before
he passed
and so it was one of his last
performances that's incredible and he
could not have been must have been
unbelievable it was unbelievable um and
he actually
performed on the keyboards with stevie
wonder and
did some stuff and
he could not have been better
[Music]